[Musique]
cela pourrait être un coup de plus porté
à l'industrie déjà lourdement frappée
par la crise une pénurie de matières
premières selon la fédération française
du bâtiment et la fédération des
industries mécaniques en maintenant les
prix ont bondi jusqu'à 40% pour le
letton l'aluminium le bronze l'acier
aurait pris lui 100% six mois
l'explication serait toute simple la
bonne v loi de l'offre et de la demande
alors que les producteurs des matières
en question avait posé le pied sur le
frein avec la pandémie la reprise
économique dans certains pays et
notamment la chine a été plus importante
que prévu du coût trop de demandes pas
assez d'offres et les prix augmentent
cqfd
tout cela engendre donc des chaînes de
production à l'arrêt et du chômage
partiel pour certaines usines du retard
sur les livraisons
le secteur du btp essentiels qui fait
travailler près de 1.5 millions de
personnes en france était déjà touché
fortement par le cos vide avec un volume
d'activité en chute de 15% et pourraient
donc subir une deuxième crise qui
porterait un sérieux coup à la reprise
économique globale
espérée en 2021
[Musique]